enregistrement de la narration première
ou deuxième lorsque james avait 4 ans sa
grande soeur a disparu alors qu'elle
tournait un documentaire près de la
ville de peur qui te suivent dans le
marais landes à la toute fin on la voit
entrer dans une maison apparemment dans
la forêt de black hills
la police et le fbi ont ratissé toute
cette zone mais ils n'ont retrouvé
aucune preuve de l'existence de cette
maison james est un ami d'enfance et
aussi loin que je me souvienne il s'est
toujours demandé ce qui était arrivé à
sa soeur sa recherche effrénée pour
avoir des réponses et pour pouvoir enfin
tourner la page et le sujet de ce
documentaire
c'est quoi ça le gars qui a mis ces
images en ligne dit qu'elle vienne d'une
cassette qui l'a trouvé dans la forêt de
black hills
je crois que ça pourrait être ma soeur
tu crois vraiment que tu as heures pour
être encore là après toutes ces années
si j'ai la moindre chance de découvrir
ce qui lui est arrivé je dois essayer
selon la légende cette forêt auraient
été mous dit
vous croyez aux histoires sur la
sorcière de blair c'est quoi ces défis
samedi quelque chose on est en train de
tourner en rond
pas vrai
y'en a partout qui dessert ce genre de
trucs et si toi qui à fait tort
alès
on n'est pas tout on a trouvé des
tentateurs
mes doigts dans le magasin
je me désole